four three two one
[Applause]
oh hey you guys what's up so what's up
we got a gill again we got George again
we got kalila again we got [ __ ] thick
dick back here with Jack and we have a
special guest not tell me something
right I'm gonna tell you something right
now we have a very special guest you
know he's on a series coming out on ABC
March 27th after Roseanne Wow and it's
it's he's one of the leads he's a lead
in it and he's mr. show business is what
I like to call him mr. show business
would like to call him and he's handsome
he's likable very funny he's gifted um
his name is Oliver Hudson you [ __ ] oh
god I can't believe you here in my house
I've been looking forward to this moment
you everywhere I am this is my first
podcast you've never done a podcast but
now cherry birds have you been asked to
do a podcast no no wow no that's I'm low
key man I know no cuz David Spade told
me something about you David Spade you
did a series with David Spade all right
what's o'clock rules of engage rules of
engagement yeah and he told me right
when I put the pilot that you don't text
back yeah you're a little bit of a
mystery man yeah but you're not very
good at the text bag whoa whoa what no
no as the lead of the show that you are
it's like it's a good day two days
sometimes yeah I have to write answer me
with no get can I just intelliwhite own
can I tell you why yeah because when I
was on animal practice okay Justin Kirk
was the lead nice guide you know him no
okay nice guy he's not as blue Ezreal
okay I love you Justin if you're
listening all right but I would text him
back he would text right away but just
the reason why I spend so long not
texting you back yeah is because David
told me that you don't text back oh so
you're trying to sort of reverse flow of
whatever you're [ __ ] doing Dave and I
are in a very good run by the way of
texting Marco Polo this app thing where
you have you heard of it no it you speak
into it in its video and it sends the
video it's basically text its video text
ah and it's been going very well we've
established a very really yeah so I'm
scared now why because if I don't text
paid back I get nervous because I know
that it's a thing for him it's it's his
deep insecurities it's not just that he
liked hell's everyone I know that you
don't do it I know so it's bad for you
yeah no I know
and I'm beginning to do it I know yeah I
know let's just have a better text
relationship than what what do you think
green I you just need to respond a
little bit quicker than just say this
yeah alright let's go through the
history of our texting then okay alright
so um okay first of all look just look
answer me
Oh your number or your numbers on there
answer me answer me answer me yeah yeah
but our a his and that this is what is
weird this is where he just sends me the
funniest here's the funniest taxi ever
sir okay so that one morning where I
didn't show up I remember that morning
oh yeah what was your thought that was
rough like I was [ __ ] nervous and I
was calling him and calling him yeah
this morning he didn't wake up yes yeah
not responding yeah and I thought he
might have been dead I mean I I didn't
know I didn't know why yeah yeah
something could have happened it doesn't
show up to I don't know I didn't know
you that well some like am I gonna die
from fatness I don't know man because I
eat bad you know I'm sober
exactly you thought I relapse oh my god
so I'm not so I I haven't showed up to
work right yeah so he texts me there
right Ken Jong replace replace yeah I'm
gonna play which is a very very funny
back that was a scary day when I showed
up now oh dude yeah you are because
you're nervous anyway yeah so just being
in that have you ever worked with anyone
more insecure than me no no honestly
other than myself
yeah as we talked about dying birthday
oh my god this guy you know because I'm
better now but I would get so [ __ ] up
in my head yeah and I'm everyone hates
me and I suck to tell about that one day
there was a one day in the pilot we were
shooting on the street yeah we were
jogging yeah I was so in my head I was
freaked the [ __ ] out yeah if it was
anybody else right
I was working if I was working with
anybody else it would have been a
nightmare because it's like you know
sometimes I open up and go
feeling a little in my head you know
whatever and people go okay and then
they'll move on mm-hmm but this guy
right here this is why I love this guy
he was like what's going and he was
telling me about his experience right
how he has problems too and what I need
to do and what what a gift well I was
also tough love because it was like get
your [ __ ] together your
[ __ ] good relax calm down stop
[ __ ] going crazy right now because
before each take he spontaneously
combustible he's all [ __ ] not today
we're doing a TV show this is not a big
deal I understand couldn't just say
something okay face this is something
okay it is a big deal
well it's only is it so it's a big deal
if you make it a big deal it's all about
what how you perceive the situation
right that's what it is
life is a big deal if you make it a big
deal if you don't and it's not right so
it's about how you it's about your
thoughts I know I don't think it's that
big of a deal you're gonna you're gonna
innately act comfortable right but
you're too in your [ __ ] head and you
make yourself crazy it's easy to say you
know what this is my I'm in a very
amazing I'm in an amazing place right
now and if I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up and
everyone else [ __ ] up on set the
director [ __ ] up you [ __ ] Kraft
serves everyone [ __ ] up so we're actors
see but that's all I need to hear okay
sometimes you need a Yoda an Oracle or
right some lady cooking cookies yeah a
black lady
right cookies and then there are other
kids in there bending spoons with her
mind but I'm a part of it okay yeah yeah
I'm the one that one of the guys that
let him into the room okay right beside
guys whatever but it wasn't a one-time
fix because then throughout the show it
progressively kind of got worse we did a
scene in a barber shop with finesse
remember that all my god it was a laugh
it was the last scene of the day and we
were trying to get it and Bobby was
[ __ ] up his lines or whatever and he
had a cell phone in the sink who's
supposed to be on the phone and he would
[ __ ] up a lot and start smashing his
head with the cell phone like Paul Paul
Mike yeah oh yeah relax you're gonna
hurt yourself what we're doing a comedic
scene on a [ __ ] City
right right yeah yes full-scale
meltdowns even after oh yeah oh but the
thing isn't it again I get that because
I I'm the same same way you know I mean
you go in you put so much pressure on
yourself for a job and you really want
it bad and you go in and you [ __ ] up and
it's like life has ended it's like this
I blew it and now what now what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do yeah and you want to kill
yourself I totally understand that yeah
but what it also is is that it's that I
got the job so easy and then I'm trying
to make it hard for myself mmm I think I
subconsciously am trying to make it hard
for myself
mm-hmm I think that you are comfortable
in the chaos yes Wow that's your happy
place
you know that's not healthy it's not
healthy but that's what do you feel most
at ease yeah raisi as that sounds yeah I
feel most comfortable in the chaos in
the anxiety yeah and here's another
thing that I noticed about myself is the
neediness oh yeah oh oh my god I hate
being needy right now I mean one time I
was walking like we're all I was walking
and our executive producer Emily was in
a little golf cart right right and she
drove she saw me she [ __ ] saamiya
right she just drove past and then as
they turn the corner I got on my hands
and knees and I had a full-blown no one
on set like yeah Peter Roth who's the
president of Warner Brothers television
he's a hugger he know he's known
everybody and Bobby when he went in for
a hug good Bobby but Bobby would you go
for like a handshake and it did not work
out I put my elbow into his chest right
it was very awkward awkward hit the
president of Warner Brothers his sore
yeah in a Soloflex
and then we we cut
kind of stood there in this awkward you
know mean uh he literally thought like
you might be fired yeah I think I just
elbowed my way out of show business like
a [ __ ] MMA like Janice Sue Anderson
Silva yeah yeah yeah and of course I see
that I like to twist the knife and I'm
that's not a good thing
but that's not it will feel you know you
need to hug that guy I know but then you
know what my hugs after that we're
privileges yeah yeah
I expected it squeeze hard yeah yeah
it's fine
[Laughter]
[Music]